we're now turning to least squares which
is really the third part of the book
and an important part of the course so
we'll jump right in and i'll tell you
what the least squares problem is and
we'll get to
how to solve it actually it's the math
it's not very complicated uh what's
exciting about least squares are all the
all the things you can do with it the
applications
okay so here's the least squares problem
uh we start
with an m by n matrix a which is tall so
that means that
m is bigger than n and that says as a
set of equations
ax equals b is over determined you have
more equations than you have
unknowns and that implies that for
most uh choices of b the right hand side
there is no solution there's no x that
satisfies ax equals b
so what we're going to do is we're going
to talk about the residual
r and that's a x minus b it means it's
the residual in the equation it means
that
it's the amount by which the equation
doesn't satisfy
so if r equals 0 the residual that means
x
is actually a solution of ax equals b
now in this case when a is tall
for most b there isn't an x that makes
the residual zero so what we're going to
do
is this we're going to choose x
that makes the residual as small as
possible
and we'll use that we'll it'll be small
as possible
in the norm or the norm squared because
if you minimize the norm it's the same
as minimizing the norm squared
so that's what we're going to do we're
going to minimize the
sum of squares of the residual
that's how we're going to choose x now
this is called the objective function
it's a scalar it's a non-negative scalar
um and it's the objective function and
it's one that we want we're going to
choose x
we want that to be as small as possible
that's the
that's what we want and so we'll say
that x hat
is a solution of the least squares
problem if the following holds
if the objective value for x hat is less
than or equal to the objective value
for any other x that's it so roughly
speaking it says
it's the best it's the best if it's the
best you can do
in terms of making the residual small
okay so that's the
that's the condition x hat minimizes
the objective that's right or you would
say x hat
minimizes the norm or norm squared of
the residual
okay um now this is
got other names too this is just least
squares um and it's got many many other
names depending on the application for
example in statistics
uh people would call it regression uh
that's where you're fitting some data
and we'll see that later
okay now uh x hat um
we will shortly get to how do you
compute x hat or what is x hat there'll
be a formula for it and it will not be
unsurprising the formula
uh but for now we'll say that if you
choose x that minimizes
the the norm squared of the residual
we're going to call that a least squares
approximate solution of ax equals b
now i i have to tell you that's because
in general
it is false it this is in general we
don't have
this right that generally does not occur
um okay so some people an older
terminology for a least
squares approximate solution of this is
people say that x hat is sometimes
called a solution of ax equals b
in the least squares sense don't say
that
i'll tell you why because it's not a
solution of ax equals b
in any sense it a solution of ax equals
b is a vector that satisfies ax equals b
and x hat generally does not satisfy
that
so don't say that um it's very confusing
uh please don't say it and actually
don't hang out with people who say stuff
like
that because it's just you know it's not
cool
so but i just wanted to warn you some
people say this it's that x hat is a
solution of x
in a least square sense which doesn't
mean anything okay fine
now as i've said a couple times x hat
the solution of the least squares
problem generally doesn't satisfy a x
hat equals b
it merely minimizes the norm of the
residual it does not make it zero
now if you have an x hat that does
satisfy ax equals b
then i guarantee you it's the solution
because the norm squared of zero is zero
and norm squares don't come any smaller
than zero so it would it is
actually in that case the minimum so it
generalizes the idea of an actual
solution
i want to give a couple of uh
interpretations of least squares uh
before we get to
how do you actually compute it or or
what's a formula for it which we'll see
shortly
um so let's let a1 through a n be the
columns
of of a the matrix and then we're going
to write out
ax in terms of its columns and so
ax is well it's nothing more than a
linear combination of the columns of a
that's written here with coefficients
that are given by x
the x i's um so what it says is that the
norm
squared of ax minus b that's the
residual
is this thing minus b this is ax but
written out by columns
um and what it says is that the least
squares problem
is trying to find a linear combination
of the columns of a
that is closest to b because this is the
distance between this thing
and this thing squared so that's a
that's a geometric interpretation so
it says among all linear combinations of
the columns of a
find me one that is closest to b
okay now if x hat
is a solution to the least squares
problem then the m vector ax hat
that's this thing that would be this
thing here that is the vector which is
closest to b among all linear
combinations of the columns of a
okay i mean essentially by definition
now we have a row interpretation as well
let's let a1 tilde
transpose up to a m tilde transpose b
the rows of a
a is here it's m by n
okay so we have uh these are the rows
and the residuals now we can write it in
terms of the rows
um a i till the transpose x
is uh is going to be ax the ith
component and then minus bi so this is
this is the i component of the residual
it's a tilde transpose x minus bi
now the least squares objective we can
write well it's the sum of the squares
of the r's
so that means we just write it out this
way like that
and what that says is it's the it's the
sum
of the squares of of the residuals
um a given and the residuals are each
given by the
these things involving the rows of a
okay so
when you choose x to minimize the sum of
the squares of residuals as you do with
least squares
what you're really doing is you're
taking these sort of m
numbers you're adding them up and making
the sum as small as possible
and that's sort of a way to make all of
them small i mean they won't they won't
all be zero or
maybe even none of them will be zero but
that's kind of the idea here
okay so and we can say a couple things
actually solving the equation
ax equals b is when you make every
residual zero
as i said that's generally not possible
when they're
when the system of equations is over
determined so
instead what you're we're going to do is
as a compromise try to make
the sum of the squares small right okay
that's the row interpretation
um let's look at a little example just
to sort of get a picture for what it
looks like
um here's a matrix a i mean this is
silly and it's so simple they wouldn't
do this but we'll we'll
we'll get to that later so here's a
matrix a is three by two
and here's b and
we consider the set of equations ax
equals b well there is no solution of
that and we can quickly figure that out
because
if i told you that a times x1
x2 is equal to b like that
then we can work out some of what this
implies right from the first
the first entry of a x is going to be
2x1
and that must equal 1. so cool x1 is a
half
and the last entry says 2 x2
is equal to -1 and so that says that x1
equals a half and we just conclude that
x2 equals minus a half
oh so we know x great this is if it were
a solution
there's that middle equation and
unfortunately in that case
when we find out what it is it is going
to be
uh the second entry is not going to be
zero unfortunately it is going to be
minus one
okay so so with this choice uh
ax my ax is going uh minus b
is going to be something like zero uh
minus one
and zero so good news is
we solve the first and the third
equation uh bad news we missed on the
middle equation
okay but that's exactly kind of what
least squares is supposed to help us
with
okay so um
all right so least the least squares
problem is to choose x to minimize and
here's norm ax minus b squared and
because it's just two entries x1 and x2
i've just written it out completely here
with no vector uh no no vector matrix
notation at all it's just
it's just this is 2x minus 1 squared
plus this thing plus that thing and
these are the residuals just written now
okay now this function
is plotted here in the sense these are
level curves
so it turns out the minimum occurs when
x hat
is a third minus a third now you could
get that using calculus if you like just
take this this expression take the
partial derivative x1 set it equal to
zero
take the partial with respect to x2 set
it equal to zero and you'll find that x1
and x2 are a third and minus a third
so that's what you get and up up here
what i've plotted
is the objective which is f
so this is f of x here
like that and it has its absolute
minimum value here
at one-third minus one-third um then
what these lines
show is where it has other values so
this is when the value is one
is is one bigger than the value at x hat
and so on and so these are ellipsoids
that's not
that's i mean that doesn't these are
ellipses it doesn't that's not a
surprise well
yeah so um but the idea and you can see
that it's getting steeper and steeper
here but the small the
the value where it's smallest is right
there this is one-third minus one-third
um and uh that smallest value
is in fact norm ax minus v squared axon
minus b squared
is actually two-thirds by the way i want
to notice something
that beats our previous solute right our
previous idea was we would take x one
equals a half x two equals minus a half
that gives you this residual zero minus
one zero
and the sum of the squares of that is
one okay so
and two-thirds is indeed smaller than
one so i mean
it had to be because this is this this
is the value
that it that gives the lowest value of
the norm square of the residual
okay um and if we form ax hat we get
this vector here two-thirds
minus two-thirds minus two-thirds and
that is the linear combination
of these two columns that is closest to
the right-hand side b okay so this is
just a picture um
you can visualize it because it's in two
dimensions now we're not going to
actually be interested in
any problem with two variables we're
going to be interested in problem with
or 20 000 uh or something like that a
very large number of variables we'll see
that that's all possible
okay what we're going to do now
is actually work out the solution
of the least squares problem so
and it's going to be not too surprising
and it's going to involve
matrices and ideas that you have already
been
introduced to okay now we're going to
make one assumption
and that is that a has linearly
independent columns
right so that's going to be our our
standing assumption
for least squares now that implies that
the grand matrix is invertible
um that's something we saw uh in the
last chapter
uh that that's invertible um and then it
turns out
i'll just tell you what the solution of
the least squares problem is it's
precisely this
it's actually a transpose a inverse a
transpose b
and you will recognize that as something
you've already seen it's the pseudo
inverse
times b that's it so the pseudo inverse
is the matrix that maps the right hand
side
to the least squares solution that's
that's what that's what that's what
eight
that's what the pseudo inverse or a
dagger is
now look this is actually kind of cool
it looks like a inverse b
and in fact as you know when a is
squared a dagger
is a inverse so it's a very nice
extension
of the uh of just solving a set of
equations if you
if you if you have a square matrix a and
it's uh
its columns are inverted or as columns
are linearly independent that means it's
non-singular
it's invertible and that means the
solution is just
a inverse b now you know that when a
is tall and has uh and and has linearly
independent columns
the the solution of the least squares
problem is a dagger b so it looks the
same
um so that's the solution i'm about to
i'll show it
we'll actually show it two different
ways from two different traditions
um but i just want to mention something
uh
oh i should mention one thing it shows
you that a dagger is very closely
related to the inverse
and now you realize that what a dagger b
gives you
is not a solution it's actually least
squares approximate solution that's the
correct way to say it
um let me see a little bit about this in
um
in how this works in various computer
languages
in in some languages and or packages for
linear algebra
um there is a symbol this is not math so
this is something that just appears in
code
and it's the backslash so and the way
people write that is you write
x equals like a backslash b now
i what i have to tell you is this
everything here this is math
okay this is all in math this is this is
not math you walk over to the math
department and say hey backslash b
no one will have a clue what you're
talking about but in several packages
for linear algebra
backslash is a very cool thing what it
means is
if a is square and invertible it means a
inverse b
if a is tall and has uh linearly
independent columns it means a dagger b
so it's basically three characters to
get
the least squares solution that's what
that looks like in a lot of computer
languages
but you have to be very careful and
always distinguish between
you know you have two different dialects
you have the you have
math this is math here um and then you
also have
how it's expressed in various linear
algebra packages or languages and things
like that
but backslash is is common and you you
may see it
uh in some way depends on what languages
you you work with
okay so what we're going to do now is
we're going to derive it uh
via calculus i mean after all you did
well i didn't say you did you were
forced to take calculus
um so let's uh you know one of the few
things you actually
learn how to do in calculus is to uh is
to at least get
sufficient conditions for for a function
being minimized
so what we'll do is we're going to write
out f of x as
actually by entries so here it is you
can check
this parentheses here is actually
a x minus b sub i
it is the i component of ax minus b and
this says take the sum of the squares
but there it is written out in all its
glory
now the solution x hat
must satisfy the following that the
partial derivative
with respect to each x has to be zero at
the solution
okay now by the way uh if this were
false it would mean that if you moved a
little bit
uh in in in in the direction of let's
say the negative gradient
then what would happen is f would get
smaller and that would show that you
were a liar when you said that x hat
actually minimizes f
okay so i don't have to go into that
that's i'm remind that's that's calculus
that's
you're supposed to have seen that or
something okay
now um we can take partial derivatives
of of this thing with respect to
xk um it's kind of a pain i mean it's
not a bad thing to do
uh but you can do it the good news is
there's a lot of terms in here that
don't contain
x k and and therefore they don't matter
because they're constants and so the
partial derivative is 0.
however when you work out what the
gradient is i'm not going to go through
this derivation but it's in the book and
you can take a look at it if you like
is you end up finding that the gradient
the kth entry of the gradient which is
in fact this partial derivative is
nothing but 2a transpose
ax minus b in other words
the gradient is 2 a transpose ax minus b
actually that's kind of cool because it
it does generalize what would be the
case if a were a scalar
right if i walked up to you on the
street and said please minimize
this where everything involved is a
scalar and a
a is a scalar x scale would be the
scalar you would say no problem and you
take the derivative and the derivative
of this would be 2
times ax minus b times a
and you would say that that's equal to
0. okay and
you know you would you would derive the
solution which is silly
the solution is going to be x equals in
this case b
over a and you actually just solve the
problem
exactly so okay all i want to point out
is that this this expression for a
scalar uh
turns out the correct the expression for
a matrix is that
and they look very similar but there's a
big difference uh here
the difference is you know first of all
the a appears on the left and it's
transposed
right so uh so here's actually my advice
for how to handle things like this
when you look at a matrix equation when
there is an obvious analog
of a scalar equation um derive the
scalar equation put it on some paper or
something like that because you're going
to destroy the evidence later
okay so you you you work it out like
this you work out
the the derivative the gradient is that
that's the derivative right
then what but this just get this just
tells you look it should look something
like that but it has to be matrix
appropriate
right so for example here's what you
should not do
is say oh that's the derivative so for
matrices it should be this
right times a well because well i mean
that's the
obvious analog of this now a couple of
problems with this number one is it
it doesn't even make sense syntactically
right that
you cannot multiply ax minus b which is
a vector on the right
by this matrix a doesn't make any it
just doesn't work
so this is just very wrong but what you
do is you keep this here and then when
you
when you derive the correct matrix
equation you look at it and you go
uh-huh okay
this scalar equation generalizes to that
matrix vector equation
this way and that's this is just a very
good way to do this
okay so back to the gradient equal to 0.
when i expand this what i get is i get 2
a transpose a times x hat
minus 2 a transpose b
equals 0. and when i
move things around i move this to the
other side divide by 2 i get these
things and these equations are very
famous and they have a name
they're called the normal equations for
this least squares problem so that's the
normal equations
and you can see that the coefficient
matrix is actually the gram matrix
which we know about already okay so
that's it
and of course if a has linearly
independent columns
then that tells you that a transpose a
the gram matrix
is invertible and so i get my solution
like that which is just what we said it
was going to be
it is it is nothing more than a
dagger b it's the pseudo inverse times b
okay so that's a derivation from
calculus
i think there's a couple of weird things
about the calculus thing number one if
you go back and read the fine print in
your calculus book
it's going to tell you this it's going
to tell you that the minimizer
has the gradient equal to zero
so fine but if if you read the fine
print all the legalese what you're going
to find is
that the gradient can be zero and you
might not be a minimum
so you could be a maximum or what's
called a saddle point or something
now in this particular case everything
is cool because in fact there was only
one
solution of the gradient equals zero and
that is this one
it's this so it has to be the minimizer
but it's a little bit weird because it
could just as well have been the
maximizer
okay now the next derivation uh
is a more direct verification
verification and i personally prefer it
so here it is and we'll directly show
that x hat equal a dagger b
minimizes the norm squared of ax minus b
let's see how that works
so i'm going to define x hat to be this
thing
and then well you can just check from
that it says that
a transpose a x hat i'm just
going to use this equals a transpose b
and then from that i will rewrite that
as this it says that a transposed
times a x-hat minus b is 0.
um by the way it's pretty cool here
right uh this
some people actually make a big deal
about that equation there uh
so uh it basically says that ax hat
minus b is the optimal residual and what
this says is the optimal residual
is orthogonal to all the columns of a
because that's what this equation says
right so some people make a big deal
about that they even i think they even
call it
like the orthogonality principle or
something which is fine i don't object
but the point is it's just this equation
okay
now what we're going to do is we're
going to say now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to directly show that if you
take
any other choice of x any choice of x at
all
you will have a norm squared residual
which is at least as big as norm squared
residual ax hat i'm sorry associated
with x hat so let's see how that works
norm ax minus b squared is this and
what i have done in this equation is
very silly
what i've done is added and subtracted
the same thing inside
so here i've added ax hat and here i've
subtracted it
well that's weird like why would you do
that and the answer is hang on and wait
and we'll see
now i'm going to use i'm going to use a
formula for the
norm squared of the sum of two vectors
and that is always equal to the norm
squared of the first vector
plus the norm squared of the second
vector plus 2 times the inner product
between the two vectors
and so this i'm writing is this it's a
norm
squared of a times x minus x hat plus
norm squared of a x hat minus b squared
norm squared sorry plus and then twice
the inner product of this vector
times that vector and that's this thing
here
okay now uh because
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
do the product
transpose of a product so here i have a
times the vector x minus x hat transpose
and i'm going to rewrite that as
the i'm going to transpose each of them
and reverse the order so that's x
minus x hat transpose a transpose
a x hat minus b and now
we look up here and we realize for our
choice of x hat
uh a transpose times a x hat minus b
is zero uh and if you like you can
invoke the orthogonality principle or
whatever you like
so this this is zero and this whole
thing just goes away
and you get this and so now let's sit
back and see what equation we have
it's pretty awesome actually it says
this it says that a x hat minus b
sorry ax minus b x is anything at all
any vector at all
norm squared is equal to a
x hat minus b norm squared
plus and then this thing whatever it is
it's always positive
right so that says that this is always
bigger than that for any choice of x
period
that means we're done that that shows
you directly
that x hat minimizes norm squared
ax minus b because here i've shown that
for any other choice of x
that norm squared is at least as big
it's actually even interesting to see
what it tells you it even says that you
know how big it is depends on how far
you are from x hat
right so okay so
that's it um to see that it's unique
um we can figure that out too right um
if i had two solutions
x hat and x then uh they would both have
to have the same value and then this
this has to be zero and that tells you
x equals x hat so that that gives you
uniqueness
as well so that's the direct
verification
that the solution of the approximate
uh of the least squares problem is
nothing more than a dagger times
b so the good news is you've already
seen it you've already
you already know you've already you've
already been introduced to the pseudo
inverse
um and so on now it also tells us how we
can compute it
so um and the way we do this via the qr
factorization you'll remember that the
qr factorization
is um was one way that we had to express
the pseudo inverse and so we'll just use
that
so we'll we start by computing the qr
factorization of
a that's a equals qr that costs you two
m n
squared flops um oh let me uh point one
thing
uh out uh here um
so uh if this fails it's because a has
dependent columns but remember that's
our that's our
that's our assumption here is that the
columns of a
are linearly independent which implies
by the way that gram schmidt
will turn will terminate successfully
and it also guarantees that a qr
factorization
exists okay um now
we're going to compute x hat which is a
dagger b
which is r inverse q transpose b you'll
remember that
from last lecture and the way we do that
is we're going to form
q transpose b that's two mn flops and
then we're going to compute
x hat which is r inverse q transpose we
we calculated this
and that's an upper triangular matrix
that's solving an upper triangular a
system of linear equations with an upper
triangular coefficient matrix
and that's just back substitution and
that's n squared flops so
both of these are actually negligible
compared to this so the one that really
counts is simply the qr factorization
is two m n squared flops and by the way
this is
this is absolutely identical to the
algorithm for solving ax
equals b for square invertible a
um it's it's literally the same
algorithm right you form a qr
factorization
you form q transpose b and then you do
back substitution
with with r now if a is square
and of course this means it's invertible
this just solves ax equals b
but if a is tall then the exact same
algorithm
leads to the least squares solution so
it's kind of cool
oh and by the way this is maybe why a
lot of these
packages use this backslash notation to
represent both
solving a set of linear equations and
solving a least squares problem